late last week reports emerged that TSM
is considering the halting of a number
of its Esports operations this allegedly
comes after a year of financial
struggles amid the collapse of a 210
million dollar partnership with the now
defunct and disgrace crypto exchange
giant FTX and for League fans in
particular the most shocking part of
this report is that after a decade of
being there TSM could be selling its LCS
spot
all right so it's quite a crazy time in
Esports right now and one day your
grandkids will ask you what was it like
to live through it so I'd recommend
subscribing to the channel so you don't
miss out on any information and you
don't let them down do you remember what
you were doing in the summer of 2017
well for tsm's League of Legends team
they were doing something they did a lot
of over the years in the LCS winning the
team had just won their third LCS title
in a row their sixth overall and we're
indisputably North America's most
dominant team for tsm's LCS fans this
was their Golden Era fast forward to
last week and the situation couldn't
really be further from that a report
from the sports Business Journal stated
that according to sources TSM are
pausing their Esports efforts in several
titles and may even be selling its LCS
slot for good so to use a phrase that
has undoubtedly crossed the lips of many
TSM fans over the last few days what the
happened well let's start with FTX
in June 2021 on TSM signed a deal with
cryptocurrency exchange platform FTX
worth a reported 210 million dollars
over 10 years part of the deal involved
TSM changing their name to TSM FTX
despite right announcing they would not
be able to use that name in League of
Legends or valorin but that decade-long
deal lasted barely over a year FTX filed
for bankruptcy in November 2022 they
cited numerous corporate missteps While
others accused them of misusing customer
funds that amounted to fraud which
eventually led to the arrest of CEO Sam
bangman freed TSM announced the
suspension of their partnership with FTX
but made clear that would not affect
their operating plan they added they
were a strong profitable and stable orb
that was forecasting profitability for
the coming years last week's report from
Sports Business Journal painted a
different picture though they claimed
their sources said that TSM took a big
Financial hit when FTX and their deal
went up in Flames it was around this
time TSM announced the departure of
their LCS Academy roster which sparked
fears among fans that a full-scale
withdrawal from the scene was around the
corner on TSM subreddit CEO Reggie
implored fans to be patient and said
they could expect news on the org
doubling down on league in January 2023.
January rolled around though and Reggie
pushed that announcement to March but
when March arrived Reggie's big news did
not TSM fans were instead met with a
quote from tsm's head LCS coach Charlie
claiming the team had the lowest budget
in the league all of this sounded like
the exact opposite of the doubling down
on League that Reggie had alluded to on
March 23rd he commented on TSM subreddit
saying we over hired and expanded too
quickly with the economic downturn we
made the necessary changes to be
sustainable this was not easy our
current team is stronger and more
performant we don't see negative effects
with the changes that we've made TSM was
not headed in the right direction I am
taking a more Hands-On role in fact we
put the right decision makers in place
to be more successful long term update
we're in the process of figuring
multiple things out and will not be able
to make any sort of announcement until
everything is final and complete expect
a minimum of four to five months I'll
make a post later on why we decided to
invest less into the LCS this season and
it may have technically been an answer
of sorts albeit very brief and vague but
it wasn't received well by TSM fans you
have to remember this comes after years
of sliding LCS results but the team has
gone from title contenders to missing
playoffs altogether the fans wanted open
communication and answers from TSM but
many felt that Reggie had not only
kicked the can further down the road
he'd actually gone back on what he
previously said now to play devil's
advocate here for a second there may be
an economically sound argument behind
TSM pulling back from the LCS if it's
true we see Esports orgs across all
titles on all leagues pulling their
purse strings tighter at the moment
they're reassessing how to monetize
their brands in a scene that is rapidly
running out of speculative investment it
feels like the bubble is either bursting
or burst player salaries and operational
costs massively outstrip money coming in
from traditional Esports revenue and
investors just aren't there to cover up
those cracks it feels like every week at
the moment we hear about another org
laying off staff or dropping teams
entirely in favor of alternative revenue
streams for TSM one of those streams was
FDX with hindsight it might be easy to
look back on that deal now after fdx's
CEO is up to his neck in federal charges
and say it was a bad move and even at
the time many within Esports were
scratching their heads at the 210
million dollar deal the two companies
had signed but regardless of that it's a
prime example of a nog trying to tap
into other revenue streams to stay
afloat because as I'm sure many of you
know it's extremely difficult to survive
never mind Thrive as an Esports or if
you're not reaching out beyond what the
average fan sees last year Reggie
himself said that TSM are only
profitable because of their software
businesses websites and streaming
network not Esports one of those
software businesses is Blitz the gaming
Performance Tool which the recent Sports
Business Journal report alleges TSM will
be shifting their focus to as they hit
the pause button in a number of
different Esports now that report does
paint a link between that decision and
the FDX deal collapse and this does seem
to somewhat contradict the comment from
last November in which Reggie had said
the org was profitable even without FTX
but in that recent Reddit post we
mentioned earlier he also acknowledged
they had had to make changes to stay
sustainable so is the orc actually
profitable is it sustainable is the
collapse of the FDX deal responsible for
their alleged withdrawal from different
Esports including League only Reggie and
TSM can answer that but we've had
nothing concrete to go on and the little
information we have had either seems to
contradict previous statements that
Reggie and TSM has made or this new
report as for the validity of the report
itself TSM has neither confirmed nor
denied it however last Saturday Reggie
did say on Twitter that quote TSM is
committed to Esports we're planning to
enter CS go sometime later this year
which is a larger investment than all of
the games we've left combined TSM is
always evaluating what Esports
ecosystems are best to invest in and
will continue to enter and exit games
that whole entering and exiting games
comment could be used to support this
recent report and Travis Gafford
recently reported that A source told him
that TSM had already approached its
players with an ultimatum well the the
First Source I I heard said that they
had approached their players and
basically given them something like 24
hours to accept a minimum salary this is
is their LCS team so perhaps it's not a
case of TSM selling their LCS but it may
simply be a budgetary downscaling but
it's mostly guesswork without an
official statement and to be honest
Reggie's comments have only generated
further questions as recently as
yesterday he said on Reddit that he
couldn't comment further for business
slash legal reasons but we'll shed light
soon and that they couldn't double down
on League because of how things played
out fans will also be hoping that ready
does an AMA which he previously said was
forthcoming after Riot completed their
investigation into him the investigation
looked into allegations of Reggie's
verbal abuse of TSM staff which
ultimately saw him being fined and put
on probation this big announcement if
and when it arrives will undoubtedly
need to include solid information about
what tsm's future in League of Legends
looks like but of course league isn't
tsm's only Endeavor in fact in recent
years they've seen far more success with
other games TSM squads have dominant
donated Apex Legends they burst onto the
DOTA scene they've had their moments in
balaran and who can forget their
incredible Rainbow Six Siege
Invitational title it seems like some of
these teams are safe and yet a big
question mark still hangs over their LCS
team the team where it all started and
if that's the case then perhaps the
problem lies partially with the LCS it's
no secret that viewership has been on
the decline for years and orgs still
don't have a sustainable Revenue sharing
model with Riot we're not going to dive
into that now I do suggest you watch out
is Esports dying video for more on that
though the point here is this isn't just
a TSM problem in fact just as I was
writing this news broke the CLG is not
only selling their LCS spot but are
ceasing to be an Esports organization
entirely with mass layoffs expected this
week and an official statement coming
Thursday so what now well we could sit
here and speculate about what an LCS
without TSM would look like even if
they're in orgs in game Rivals having a
big name like TSM is arguably a net plus
for any team sharing a league with them
but Yamato Cannon doesn't believe that
recent reports spell Doom for the LCS he
said on Twitter CLG and TSM have
achieved legendary status and were an
important part of the early years I
watched them played against them and
looked up to their players times are
different now and these organizations
don't hold the same stature nor do I
think these organizations exiting spells
as much Doom as some would like to make
it out to be other organizations took
their place as the top dogs and if
they'd follow in these footsteps then
yeah I'd be worried so if they do leave
who would take their spot I've seen
names like Sentinels thrown about even a
Mr Beast team stranger things have
happened and what will be happening to
tsm's other teams and will they really
be entering Counter-Strike now in a big
way Reggie has now said that move would
be a larger investment than all of their
other games combined and it's fair to
ask what could be acts from their
portfolio to accommodate that investment
really all of this speculation rides on
one thing that TSM fans have been
waiting for months for Now official
statements sooner or later TSM and
Reggie are going to need to announce
their intentions when it comes to League
of Legends and their whole Esports
operation in general if the decision is
to leave the LCS we'll be back to give
you all the details and what exactly
that would look like
thank you